i can i can differentiate between tap
water and like normal water but not like
everyone can not say like voss water i
don't i don't understand
water what the [ __ ] have you never heard
of voss water it's like
it's like the really really posh water
that comes in a glass bottle um you can
see it on screen now
and it's only at like the really high
class hotels and i've like
i've sampled one before i remember
because it was like i
i was really really thirsty and it was
the only it was it was any water
available
and um it just tastes like water there
is no difference between
the bottled water brands i'm convinced
and then when you watch how they half of
them [ __ ] get their water
half of it comes from the same [ __ ]
place which is just the normal taps that
all the people are using in the area oh
dude you know what's the one type of
person that i'll never be friends with
when someone will take a sip of water
and being like oh this is hard water can
i get some soft water please
that i knew people like that i know
people like that in california
[ __ ] hate you i knew someone who
could only drink uh
a brand of humber which brand it was
made with avionics they literally
refused to use any other water and if
they used
boiled water like in like cup noodles it
had to be boiled evion
can you believe this yo but i don't know
man i i i don't
like tap water like i i i i i i have
gone through a phase where i've got
interviews on youtube and then this is
what happens man he's like only everyone
for me
well i mean because is tap water
drinkable in the uk
yeah yeah it's drinkable in the uk where
i live i've grown up where everywhere
i've lived in my life tap water has
sucked and i've heard about this
mythical good tap water that people
talk about sometimes connor's one of
those people comes australia bro we have
great tap water i i've i've always had
like shitty taps it depends because like
if you get it from a quarter to me this
this clearly tastes like tap water
because like if i can taste
the sink in tap water then then it's
it's like
inferior water for me i don't want to
taste i don't want to taste something
metallic i don't want to
sometimes i i get the hard water thing
because sometimes i drink tap water and
i'm like i feel more dehy
i feel even more dehydrated than
when when i first drank this water i i
feel like the
the best time to like really judge how
good water is
is when you're hungover because when i'm
hungover there are definitely different
levels
i feel different levels of hydration
when i'm hungover because i need
i when you're feeling like [ __ ] and you
just want to feel hydrated again
that's when like i i i will stick by the
bottled water
every time over tap water i mean i'll
take tap water
i just drink a liter a liter of whatever
is near me oh dude like if if i'm like
if depending on how hungover i am i'll
[ __ ] drink a litter of toilet water
like any anything to just get
you can drink toilet water it's clean
yeah i know that's what i'm saying
[Music]
that's what i'm saying right it's like
it's like you ever like turn your bidet
on and go
i have seen a japanese youtuber do that
before oh
god and it wasn't didn't go didn't go
out well
but yeah i don't know i guess maybe it's
because at least in sydney like
out it's like bottled water is almost
non-existent
in sydney because legitimately the tap
water is just as good as the bottled
water right and also bottled water in
australia is [ __ ] expensive it's like
you
a bottle like that big is like four
dollars i only buy bottled water because
i'm out and i
can't just find a tap to drink well i
mean here right
yeah yeah no here like because you know
bottled water is cheap right it's like
100 yen
so that it's a little bit more
affordable but in australia if someone
was like yeah i'm just going to go to
the woolies and buy a four-door bottle
of water what about what about water
fountains do you drink from water
fountains
i mean i drink from water fountains when
i am
desperate it depends where yeah it
depends on where how clean or dirty the
water
i feel like a lot of this has come up
from my upbringing because in thailand
you can't drink
tap water so i've i've just gotten used
to being like
always that makes sense but like i i do
genuinely think the taste of tap water
tastes like [ __ ] where i am
right like i can taste the chalk where i
in japan no in brighton
in brighton i'm in japan it just tastes
metallic
it tastes really metallic and i'm not a
fan of the metallic taste i i mean i it
was nice in wales
and it was kind of meh in london and
here i filtered it but in london it
[ __ ] sucks yeah i don't know
but like london are you getting that
like cholera [ __ ] dude
i don't trust the water in london i mean
wales is nice
the quarry was right next to me as well
no i feel like because i i don't know
how it is in other countries but
everywhere i've been to where it's like
a big city normally i don't
tap water to taste like [ __ ] countryside
yeah yeah
like if okay if you're in hotel right
and you're and you're really thirsty
do you go for the bathroom water or do
you go for the
do you go for like the fridge mini bar
water well you pay for it
yeah no [ __ ] way am i paying for that
one no no i'm not paying for that no
i'm going straight to the tower no
because
that's the worst tasting water the hotel
bathroom water is like the worst now
dude
that's that's where i draw the line
that's where i draw the [ __ ] mind i'm
never paying for water in a hotel
are you [ __ ] kidding me that's
ridiculous it's like yeah i feel like a
hotel's the one place that should not be
allowed to charge
which is just like being somewhere and
you're gonna charge me for water
[ __ ] off yeah in a way i mean for me i i
genuinely can't taste the [ __ ]
difference anyway so if i'm like shout
out to the hotels that give you bottled
water for free
yeah shout out to the you are the real
g's yeah so i don't have to [ __ ] go
through your voss water
and not like just one bottle they give
you like four and they're like go ham
man like
we fill them all every day and the best
is like when you come back from a day
out and the bottles are like bad yeah
yeah
yeah that's the good [ __ ]